les scènes coupées des réunions chez
facebook qui on va lancer facebook
gaming wombats concurrence et twitch
l'eia huawei pour ça on rachète mixeur
6g salle jean jaurès toujours défini les
gars ça fait un an qu'on en parle on le
lance autres plateformes de sony vidéo
mais on est déjà lancé ah oui depuis
plusieurs semaines et ça marche
ouais version augmentée non j'ai encore
au moins chez electronic arts ce mois
attendez oh oh j'ai eu les fans sans
suez à l'érotique oui on les aisselles
et donc c'est là qu'est ce que vous
faites
bah c'est pour mon annif hans à non il
faut payer pour moi les photos ma carte
bleue oh non et oui chez astana on les
gardait d'accord personnes utilisent un
service stadium ne vous êtes viré trader
chez korn à regarder légalement par le
mot sur twitter corona et entraîné des
pics je le savais en avant le perco la
cour la partie
tout promo est bonne à prendre
non chez twitch séviraient il nous l'a
mis dans la tête on est viré
et on y va mental est celle ichi fallait
mais vaour moi aussi et c'est bon bien
atteindre la cagnotte pour
l'anniversaire de sylvie on lui offre un
thermomix elle va adorer chez lui c'est
qu'il sylvie aucune idée l'ado remplir
des cagnottes à des gens que je sais pas
qui c'est aux oliviers veut un nouveau
spa et bas 20 euros pour le dire
[Musique]
le bêtisier des rémoises les patinages
séparation et après je l'attends 4 à 13
ans sympathique ça fait plaisir au mieux
par contre les gars ça les met plus à
séverac et le mans tournée tu as décidé
de fonctionner dit attends je refuse de
révéler les nouvelles mois on s'attaque
pas aux normes ne suivez moi très bien
[Musique]
c'est pour s est abîmé au dicton on
prend là bas salaires il continue
d'aller d'avoir regardé il fonde et
story reprend l'idée
oui oui on est dans un niveau de théâtre
c'est qu'ils te donne plus gros de ces
de l'after effect aux jouets en fait ils
séparent les trois personnages
principaux à l'est de rabat à la
première quelles idées de merde allez
bon courage
c'est l'after effect encore bon bah
c'est la belle affaire ça je prends tout
de suite j'ai en fait je fais j'aime pas
j'aime pas du tout enfin c'est toi je
n'ai pas senti en fait non mais c'est
pour lui c'est bon voilà on fait pour
lui
voilà pas les allées voilà oui parce
qu'on a une équipe de designers qui
pourront proposer des visuels niche à
cause des hoquets sa belle ou ma carte
bleue baboo pantalon mon téléphone à la
carte bleue oui je comprends pas et
profanes pardon ça ça sera jamais mon
fils ait jamais faudrait mettre des
serrures ben oui puis des portes autour
des cycles mais will autour des saveurs
que c'est une bonne idée
mouais à bing maps auch tarbes et
empoche ça fait une peau qui est cette
nouvelle ma ceinture sinon j'ai
discrètement au attendait un poteau tous
les gars ça fait plus d'un an qu'on en
parle il faut qu'on laisse notre patrie
je vais des blagues je rajoute des
blagues pour les gens qui ont subi des
choux gras des finales les gars du béton
mais lui ça fait un an qu'on en parle
et si on se plante cerises et une vidéo
de cyprien
la merde ça il ya sans doute des coréens
savent où j'étais moi les déplorons là
j'avais dit colonna david cronin tu
fermes ta gueule tu es viré didier jeu
j'ai bien aimé ta femme tu as trouvé
avec moi à didier été adopté personne ne
t'aiment
et c'est pas didier que je parle c'est à
julien jocelyn le trouvez bien
et oui tout ce que je dis je veux pas
pour avoir une plus grosse option voulez
pas vous ambiancer un petit peu avec moi
au début c'est joe dassin tracassé par
action c'est dur ce qui se passe et plus
tard je viens très peur d'utiliser cela
qu'anwar positif c'est que j'allais dire
et si tu te fois ci ça fait pas les
faits jean rannou la moue la prof tu
nous dois sans ballon mais ces bois le
moins riche de budo droit légal qu'est
ce que c'est à nous la moue là
non si c'est pour aller si c'est pareil
c'est pas mal moi là j'avais dit vous
voulez qu'on aille je ferai bien j'en
suis sûr cela passe aussi plusieurs
aussi possible nous l'as moulins oui à
merci je pense qu'à un scotch s'il fait
trop mal je le passe ainsi de la
bouilloire à nous je ne tourne qu'à
raqqa n'arrive pas en déclencher et même
parfois dos d'un coup à nous la boule
ouais je pensais que c'était un peu plus
impressionnant oui moi aussi ça m'a déçu
yes